so I think it's human behavior and so
the the way that we describe this is
local versus global benefit a simple
example is like if I want to have a
six-pack why does Sarah go grab a piece
of cake rather than grabbing a piece of
chicken breast because the local benefit
the acute benefit of having a piece of
cake is higher in the small in the local
region yeah but the global benefit for
her body is lower and so humans in
general will tend to optimize for local
benefit rather than Global and the
people who can simply optimize for
Global benefit for their system-wide
benefit are the ones that get the
biggest compounding returns over the
Long Haul